les le héros préféré de beaucoup
d'enfants l'inventeur de titeuf le
dessinateur zep vient de sortir son
dernier album de bd le 12e
le plus gros tirage de l'édition cette
année en france un vrai phénomène
durable pourquoi depuis 16 ans un tel
engouement pour titeuf ses potes et ses
copines
thierry ce temps fleurs et huilé piette
c'est le douzième album de titeuf il
s'intitule le sens de la vie et sur la
couverture site off à la tête à l'envers
et l'on se dit qu'une fois de plus tout
cela est particulièrement bien vu il ose
parler à l'enfant de ses vrais problèmes
de son existence de sa transformation de
ses rapports aux autres
quelque chose de métaphysique mais il le
fait avec une naïveté un charme et sans
oublier quelques blagues scatologiques
qui permet à l'enfant de se dire oui
mais j'ai aussi droit de de régresser le
succès phénoménal de titeuf ne doit donc
rien au hasard
a paris une exposition à la fois
pédagogique et ludique sur
l'apprentissage de l'amour a déjà attiré
300 mille visiteurs les enfants s'y
amuse comme des petits fous autour de
sujets qui les préoccupent vu leur âge
j'appuie qu à chaque fois qu un garçon
le tout ce qu elles veulent donner un
triple triple crise identitaire et du ch
m'embêtait ce jour
et on prend une gifle comme ils sont
contenus dans aucun sujet ne semble
tabou avec des questions que les parents
ne savent pas toujours comment aborder
ça allait pas se rapprocher des années
qu'on connaît pas dans l'enceinte de
l'école était un étranger qui dit alors
comment fait-il z pour intéresser des
générations d'enfants trouver les mots
justes et réinventer sans cesse son site
je suis titeuf qui fait son journal
intime donc je tombe des pages sans
aucun problème puisque c'est mon
quotidien
et puis après je referme mon cahier je
redeviens un personnage adulte moi j'ai
besoin d'avoir un peu de un peu
d'intimité pour redevenir ce personnage
comme superman qui va se changer dans la
cabine téléphonique tient vraiment trop
nul le monde change mais les
préoccupations des enfants reste
immuable
voilà peut-être pourquoi le succès de
titeuf ne se dément pas dit il